[Music]
welcome back today I'm really excited to
tell you about kind of this concept of
sparsity and compression and
specifically address the question of why
natural signals are so compressible
audio signals images streaming
television all of these signals are
massively massively compressible right
now you are watching this video this is
being streamed in a compressed format
from Google servers directly to your
screen okay and why is the world so
compressible that's the question we're
gonna ask today this is one of my
favorites I'm super excited to tell you
about this it's surprisingly related to
the age-old question of if you had a
room full of monkeys banging on
typewriters would they eventually come
up with the complete works of
Shakespeare okay so that's it's closely
related to this idea of compressibility
and the rarity of natural signals that
we care about images and audio and and
and written books and texts the rarity
of those structured signals in the vast
vast space of randomness that is
possible okay and one of the reasons
this is among my favorite lectures to
give is because it involves massively
big numbers and ever since I was a
really small kid I loved thinking about
big big numbers okay and here we're
gonna talk about some of the biggest
numbers you're going to experience in
your your daily lives okay so we're
going to start with a thought experiment
we're going to imagine that we have
images that are really really crude okay
so we're gonna have 20 by 20 so 20 by 20
black-and-white images so all that you
can have our zeros and ones telling you
if your pixel is black or white in a
twenty by twenty grid okay so I'm not
going to draw the exact twenty by twenty
grid but it's pretty you know it's a
pretty coarse grid of pixels
how many possible images in this twenty
by twenty black-and-white pixel space
can you have okay this is a question
that is pretty pretty easy to answer if
you're familiar with with powers okay so
in each pixel you have two choices black
and white and there are 20 times 20 or
400 pixels so you have 2 to the power
400 possible
black and white 20 by 20 images this is
bigger than the 10 to the 80 nucleons in
the known universe nucleons in the
universe and so what that tells you is
that even these silly little 20 by 20
images you could barely draw a smiley
face or a peace sign or something like
that in this tiny little image space
even those images have more possible
images than there are nucleons in the
known universe this is larger than
astronomical how big this pixel space is
okay and so imagine that instead of this
dinky little pixel space now we have
full mega pixel space and instead of
black and white you know zeros or ones
you have full color depth you have you
know thousands or millions of choices of
the color and the you know brightness
and saturation at every single one of
those million pixels now you have
something like thousands or millions to
the power millions and every year you
know your phone has more and more pixels
in its camera more megapixels this space
of images this pixel space is almost
mind-bogglingly large it is so obscenely
large how large this pixel space is it's
hard to even fathom even this twenty by
twenty pixel space is bigger than the
universe this pixel space is is vast
beyond imagination and I want to kind of
take you down this road of how big this
space is and why this is at least going
to give us some hint of why pictures are
so compressible or at least pictures we
care about okay so the space of pictures
of what we're going to call natural
images now natural doesn't mean
pictures of streams and mountains and
goats and things like that it also means
everything you'd ever see like this pen
or a coffee cup or this picture that
you're seeing on your screen right now
and me talking to you or there's a
picture of you looking at your screen
there's a picture of you being born
whether or not someone took that picture
it exists in natural image space there's
a picture of you being born from every
possible camera angle there's a picture
of every moment of your entire life that
lives inside of this image space so this
natural image space of things you would
ever see with your eyes is also vast
beyond imagining it encapsulates
everything you will experience at least
in megapixel resolution in your life
from every camera angle okay so your
natural image space is huge but pixel
space is huger it's even bigger than
your whole experience and everything you
could experience and things you can't
even imagine experiencing pixel space is
bigger and here's why if you randomly
drew an image from pixel space if you
just randomly put values in for every
single pixel and you do this over and
over and over again a million times a
billion times a trillion times you will
only ever get TV static stuff like this
that looks like white noise for my
younger viewers TV static is what
happened when you used to turn your TV
on and you didn't have a channel it
didn't turn blue it turned into this
kind of pixelated snowy fuzzy white
noise that's that's the that's the basic
signal of the universe if you just
randomly pulled an image from pixel
space you get TV static and you could do
that over and over and over again from
now until the end of time and you will
only ever get random noise in a
megapixel image space you'll never
randomly assign bits and get a coffee
cup or a picture of a dog or a hurricane
or something structure that humans care
about so these are two big concepts our
world of pictures we care about is vast
it encompasses everything you could
possibly take a megapixel image of that
you would care about but the space that
it
in the natural the the pixel space that
natural images live inside of is so much
bigger the natural images occupy a
minuscule tiny fraction a tiny corner of
this possible pixel space okay and so
that gives you this idea that even
though this space is huge
a lot of the pixels we use a lot of
those million pixels or more that we use
to represent those natural images are
somehow redundant because they are also
giving us the flexibility of coding this
even vaster space of randomness that our
natural images live inside of and so
that basic redundancy the fact that our
natural image space is a tiny tiny
almost immeasurable fraction of pixel
space is what allows us to compress and
define other representations where these
images are sparser or can be described
with less numbers less than a million
numbers because most of those million
numbers those degrees of freedom those
pixels are allowing you to code up this
pixel space also this random white noise
okay so that's at least how I think
about this the vastness of image space
is is how I think about compression and
why signals are compressible now I said
that these images these natural images
live in a tiny corner of pixel space
that's not entirely true if they lived
in a little corner a pixel space then we
would just go to that corner and we
would only look there to represent our
images and we get really really good
compression for free we know exactly
what to measure to get those images what
really happens is that natural images
live in this kind of spider web spread
throughout this extremely high
dimensional million dimensional mega
pixel image space there are these like
gossamer spider web threads maybe
there's this thread over here that looks
like trees and a thread over here that
looks like dogs and you know it's all
connected but it doesn't live in one
corner it is immeasurably thin web of
natural images inside a pixel space
though okay now again this is kind of
philosophical stuff this might actually
sound familiar to you so Bohr Hayes in
his famous book labyrinths writes about
the the library of Babel it's this kind
of thought experiment that he ran where
he had this infinite library with these
hexagonal Carol's and inside of these
every single book that could possibly be
written was written so his book this
labyrinths was on that shelf and next to
it was another copy of labyrinths with
one letter changed and millions and
trillions and quadrillions of copies of
this book with just small variations
filled Carol after Carol on this
hexagonal pattern on to infinity okay
it's this beautiful concept
this is Bohr his kind of wrestling with
this idea of the infinite and his
conception of the infinite is basically
book space okay so we have pixel space
he was thinking about book space you
could think about audio space even this
goes all the way back to Aristotle
Aristotle was talking about how if you
kind of you know randomly dropped all of
the Greek letters you had a huge
collection of Greek letters made of gold
and you dropped these on the city
streets would they ever randomly fall
into a sentence or a poem or something
that made sense to humans okay so people
have been wrestling with this concept of
the infinite and the vastness of signal
space for millennia and now with
advances in applied math and statistics
and optimization we're finally starting
to understand kind of where our natural
images live inside of these this image
space and where our signals live in
signal space so I want you to think
about you know kind of where you stand
on this if you had enough monkeys
banging on typewriters for long enough
you know would they ever come up with
this kind of corner of signal space that
actually matters to us humans okay
so we're gonna talk more about this
we're especially going to exploit this
for compression ourselves we're going to
the fact that these natural images are
somehow special in this nearly infinite
signal space we're going to exploit that
structure and we're going to use that
for for compression and we're going to
use that in the context of sparsity all
right thank you